hola muchas gracias por la invitación
pues como avances de los sectores
sociales el eje en américa latina
podemos encontrar realmente una lista
muy variable que cada uno de los países
ha ido adoptando países como colombia el
matrimonio igualitario la adopción por
ejemplo ya son una realidad pero en
lugares como ecuador o perú siguen
siendo discusiones muy importantes para
los sectores sociales el eje que
hablamos específicamente de los derechos
y la garantía de derechos de personas
trans vamos a encontrar unas diferencias
muy grandes en países como bolivia que
por ejemplo tienen una ley que pretende
ser integral que garantiza algunos de
los derechos pero colombia por ejemplo
está hasta ahorita en esta planeación
para postulación en el congreso esto lo
que implica también es que a nivel
latinoamericano pues hemos encontrado
estas diferencias sobre cómo podemos
garantizar efectivamente nuestros
derechos y también las restricciones que
tenemos como países en cada uno de ellos
las personas de los sectores en el gp
para acceder a los mismos en todos
ustedes menciona a las persona trans
precisamente desde la fundación que
usted dirige una de las principales
luchas es que tengan derecho a una
personalidad jurídica y a un nombre
acorde con la identidad de género qué
tan difícil ha sido lograr esa meta y
qué barreras siguen encontrando
pues el caso por ejemplo de colombia
desde el año 2015 el decreto 227 permite
que podamos hacer esta corrección y
camino el componente de sexos y
recientemente una sentencia te 033
e insta a la registraduría que puedan
modificar esta categoría para que las
personas nominales también puedan
acceder a este procedimiento y hacer
esta corrección en el componente de sexo
pero pues hemos notado que esto no
solamente implica que el estado pueda
expedir una ley sino que además tienen
que garantizar la gratuidad en el acceso
al derecho a la identidad y además tenga
que garantizar la información para que
en diferentes lugares pueda ser una
realidad a más o menos 7 años desde que
se implementó por ejemplo esta política
en colombia hemos encontrado que han
existido barreras sistemáticas
estructurales que han impedido que
podamos acceder al derecho y esto en
países garantistas de este derecho a la
identidad como colombia pero si nos
trasladamos a otros países de la región
todavía no sean las garantías y la
posibilidad de que las personas trans
podamos cambiar y modificar nuestro
registro y cuál es el panorama en la
región frente a la violencia contra la
comunidad lgtb y lg bético más
creemos que desde muchas organizaciones
hemos hecho un rastreo sistemático y
además de todo hemos identificado los
datos de violencias de asesinatos de
homicidios y de muertes que surgen en
razón de las barreras de acceso a los
derechos fundamentales como la salud del
trabajo la educación y si hemos
encontrado un aumento para el año pasado
en la fundación gat en colombia un
aumento del 27 por ciento de los casos
registrados de asesinato de personas
trans y esto pues también nos traslada a
poder analizar las políticas que desde
los estados le están garantizando los
derechos